موجز الاخبار من الجزيره لما كنتم السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله قال الجيش الاوكراني ان
القوات الروسيه نفذت 7 10 ضربه جويه واكثر
من 60 هجوما صاروخيا على عده جبهات في
اوكرانيا من جهتها قالت تسلطات المحليه
المواليه لروسيا في دونيتك ان اكثر من 170
صاروخا وقذيفه نوكرانيه ارتدت مناطقه
سكنيه ومنشات للبنيه التحتيه في المقطعه
شدد الرئيس الاوكراني
هاتفي
على ضروره الالتزام بالنقاط ال 10 لتحقيق
السلام وفقا لصيغه الاوكرانيا بدوره حضر
وزير الخارجيه البريطاني من استغلال
محادثه السلام في اوكرانيا كغطاء لاعاده
التسلل في روسيا
قال المتحدث باسم الكريم الذي نتجاهل
الهواجس الامنيه الروسيه بشان اتفاقيه من
شكل مقدمه لمواصفاتها بالعمليه العسكريه
الخاصه في اوكرانيا من جهته قال نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن الروسينا عدو روسيا ليس فيك
كيف بل في اوروبا وامريكا الشماليه
واليابان واستراليا ونيوزلندا وغيرها
بحث الرئيس التركي
في مجال الطاقه وانشائي المركز الاقليمي
في اسطنبول
السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي عن
قلقي الاتحاد بما وصفها بالسياسه في تركيا
في عدم الانضمام للاجراءات التقليديه
الاوروبيه ضد روسيا ياتي ذلك قبل اجتماع
حاسم لوزاره الطاقه الاوربيه
اكد الرئيس التركي في اتصال مع نظيره
الروسي ضروره التطهير الحدود مع سوريا
بعمق 30 كم ممن سماهم الارهابيين في
المقابل قال الكريم لن ان الرئيسين بحثا
حل النزاع على اساس اتفاقي سوتشي هذا
وافدت مصادر محليه للجزيره ان القواتيه
التركيه قصفت نقاطا عسكريه عده لما تعرفوا
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه الشماليه سوريا
الاحد بعد ان تبادل مجهولون اطلاق النار
مع الشرطه والقبله صوتيه على افراد من
الشرطه من بعثه الاتحاد الاوروبي وحضر
مفوض السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي من هجمات محتمله على البعثه
الاوروبيه وقال باحلف انيته بمحاسبه
الضالعين في الهجوم على الدوريه الاوروبيه
وفيما عقد الرئيس اجتماعا قارئا لمجلس
الامن القومي لبحث الازمه دعت واشنطن الى
ضغط النفس
اشكركم على متابعه الموجزه لما كنتم طابق
اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]